-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching at home.
Thank you for being here again.
Well, guys, we're right in the
middle of the holiday season.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you feel the vibes?
And if you're waiting to buy
a Christmas tree,
you better hurry, because due to
high demand and low supply,
prices are soaring.
Yeah.
I'm trying to get ahead of this.
That's why every night,
on the way home,
I cut one branch off
the Rockefeller Center
Christmas Tree.
I just take it away from there.
I'm getting there.
♪ Christmastime ♪
Yeah, it's the holiday season,
and today, New York
got an early Christmas gift.
Aaron Judge is coming back
to the Yankees!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
That's right.
Yankees superstar Aaron Judge
has decided to stay in New York,
agreeing to a nine-year,
$360 million contract.
When he heard that,
Babe Ruth said, "What the hell?
I got paid in peanuts and
Cracker Jacks."
$360 million.
Today, Judge walked into
the owner's office and said,
"You're in my seat."
What a deal.
Aaron is now the only person
who can afford a beer
in Yankee Stadium.
-Oh!
-Yeah.
It's true.
The good news is,
Judge got $360 million.
The bad news is,
the rest of the team
is now getting paid in crypto.
Did you guys hear about this?
Apparently, former president
Trump's lawyers
just turned over more
classified items to the FBI
after finding them at
Trump's storage unit in Florida.
Yeah, we were just
a week away from
our most classified secrets
ending up on
an episode of "Storage Wars."
I mean, really.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A storage unit.
You know that you've stolen
too many top secret documents
when you can't even fit them
all in your house.
You know what I'm saying?
Meanwhile, last night, Trump
hosted an event at Mar-a-Lago
that featured a prominent
QAnon conspiracy theorist.
It's not good when you mingle
with a conspiracy theorist
to distract from your dinner
with a white supremacist.
You know what I'm saying?
Switching gears, I saw
that TikTok just released
their 10 most popular videos
of 2022.
And there's some
pretty cool videos in there.
For example, the top video
was of a chocolatier making
a life-sized giraffe.
Take a look at this.
♪♪
Yeah, I mean,
that's impressive,
but, unfortunately, it bumped
this video off the list.
-♪ Ahhhhh ♪
-Aah!
-What's going --
-Oh, my God!
-Another video in the top 10
was a remix of the corn kid.
-Oh.
-Check this out.
Yeah. That's great. It's cute.
But, once again, that means that
this video got snubbed.
-Wow.
Wow.
And, finally, Lizzo cracked
the top 10 for her video
where she shows the choreography
to "About Damn Time."
Here it is.
-Feelin' fussy.
Walkin' in my Balenci-ussies.
-Yeah, that's right. Yeah.
But, sadly, that knocked
this from the top 10.
-Who painted the Mona Lisa?
Mona Lisa.
-Yeah.
-Da Vinki?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Better luck next year.
"Da Vinki?"
-"Da Vinki?"
-Hey, guys, get this --
airline passengers in Europe
will soon be allowed
to use 5G service
to make phone calls on board.
The only thing worse than your
seatmate trying to talk to you
is your seatmate
trying to talk to someone else.
It's like,
"Hey, can you hear me?!
I'm on a plane right now!"
Yeah, this means no more putting
your phone on airplane mode.
Yep, everyone's like, "Finally,
we can stop pretending
to do that."
Good.
Some entertainment news.
"Wednesday" is on track
to become Netflix's
most-watched English-language
TV series ever.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know these
are crazy times when a show
about a depressed goth child is
what makes us all happy.
I mean...
It's good, it's good.
Everyone's talking about
the holiday action movie
"Violent Night," as well.
It did surprisingly well
at the box office,
so they're re-editing
old holiday favorites now
to capitalize on this new trend.
-Really?
-Look at this ad I saw today.
-They tried to take
everything he had,
but this Christmas,
George Bailey fights back.
He's smooth-talking,
hard-drinking,
and he's got a message
for anyone who crosses him.
-You're going to die!
-[ Screams ]
-Every time a bell rings,
George kicks some ass.
-Where's that money,
you stupid old [bleep]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Wow!
"Stupid old --" beep!
-"Where's that money at?"
Right now, a lot of people are
putting out holiday decorations.
I saw one homeowner
in Wisconsin --
this made me laugh --
who kept it very simple.
Look at this video.
♪♪
That's fantastic.
That's the most effort someone's
ever put into no effort.
-Guys, finally, we have
exactly eight shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It is time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
-♪ "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters" ♪
♪ Eight days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a heavenly Christmas sweater
from the "Countdown
to Christmas" cabinet.
Since there are
eight shows left,
let's open door number 8,
shall we?
Hello.
-Hello.
-This is it right here.
I'm very excited about this one.
-It's a good one.
-Last one was hard to top.
The last one, we had someone's
head coming through a chimney.
-Exactly.
-Yeah. Here we go.
Let's see what we have tonight,
yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Heavy.
It's got some weight to it.
Yeah.
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Epaulets?
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
This is a heavy one.
Everyone,
look at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drumroll,
please?
[ Drumroll ]
284!
♪♪
Hey. I'm Jimmy.
Nice to see you.
Can you stand over there?
Welcome to the show.
What is your name?
-Catalina.
-Catalina, where are you from?
-Portugal.
-Hey!
Come on!
I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm happy, too.
-This is your color, basically.
-Yeah. It's my favorite color.
-It just happened that pink
is your favorite color?
Do you have anything like this
in Portugal?
-No. I'm so happy.
-Yes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, you haven't
tried it on yet.
-I'm sure it's going to be fine.
-Can you -- Can you try it on?
-Yeah, of course.
-Yeah?
Here you go.
It's got a lot of --
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, okay, I can hear you.
Catalina, oh.
[ Laughs ]
Wow.
Get your -- Oh --
You have -- Oh.
Get your hair out.
You look gorgeous.
That's what I'm talking --
Look at that.
That's how you rock the sweater.
Beautiful!
One more round of applause
for our winner.
Congratulations.
Thank you for being here.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with
Michelle Pfeiffer, everybody.
Come on back, now.